[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to bonehead this week's bonehead
of the week
we have special edition of bonehead of
the week this week not only do we have
our normal pole
which is not surprising who won and i
was surprised how close it was though
and we'll explain that but we also are
going to go through bone head madness
that we just went through and who the
champ is the champ the champ champ which
i actually
i was kind of disappointed but it is
what it is the vote is what it is there
was no rigging there was no there was no
rigging of the machines
um there was
there was
there was no um bamboo ballots or
anything like that none of none of the
cyber ninjas nonsense
it was fair a free fair election and we
will report the results
as they came in and as they were
um even as disappointed as i am in the
results
well i mean you know i really i wanted
marjorie taylor green to win this
conference yeah i wanted marge madness
right i really wanted i wanted it to be
because we can't say march madness it's
not right it's not march madness yeah
yeah because like ncaa and cbs will come
after us right so we can't say march
madness can't say it because that's not
what it it is madness right right it's
it's it's a madness it's not march
madness it's bonus it's in march it was
in march yeah it was it was in march
yeah yeah right i mean we we wrapped it
up in march right like the poll ended in
march i believe right yeah well yeah
well yeah the uh well i mean officially
i guess you'd say right right we start
we we started the championship game and
the game was one in march
but we i wanted marjorie taylor green
and she really looked like she might
honestly thought you know she was
kicking butt those first two rounds
and ron desantis came in and just
stomped her ass yeah who knew that's why
that's why the cinderella story of ron
desantis because really he is kind of
the cinderella story right yeah he's so
underrated he's such a [ __ ] putts and
but he came in he he signed the don't
say gay bill he's been running around
impersonating donald trump so hard he's
he's getting really good at it yeah yeah
i saw him earlier
right and he's he really he needs to get
the [ __ ] tie down i mean he's he's
gained the weight so he's a fat slob now
but he really he needs to dye the hair
the lean we need the lean right he needs
the shoes he's got to lean in but he but
he really does have the bigotry down oh
yeah
that hating people the hate the bigotry
the misogyny the buffoonery he's got
that down [ __ ] pat it is beautiful
his impersonation on that level but the
physical import he really needs and and
he's got the cadence down the hand yeah
but he's got to work on the voice the
hair yeah and the outfit it really needs
to be it's almost like you know the
longer they spend in the same state like
he's just like
absorbing
those properties you know right and he's
just becoming
right right
do you think he's like do you think
it's like uh in marvel where
bruce banner becomes the hulk and they
merge oh right yeah yeah it's like ron
desantis and donald trump are like
merging into one oh that's yeah
you know or it could be it could turn
out to be like that scene from the fly
um
if anyone hasn't seen that you should go
watch that with jeff goldblum great
movie uh but i think it's like that
scene for the fly where it's like you
know he tries to teleport the fly gets
trapped in there dna
and then by the end of the movie
he's just a big [ __ ] fly you know
right so who knows he might be like a
like a
another trump or he might be worse than
a trump you know so you think like it's
a clinical transition then who knows i
mean there might be some like physical
kind of changes that happen obviously
like you know he's like face-off type
stuff you know i mean you know
i'm just saying no i mean there was that
conspiracy that joe biden and donald
trump did do a face-off uh situation
which could totally be real right which
is hilarious because
if trump is actually the president right
now and and and it's just to face that
switch right right
uh
then he is really disappointing to all
right i know he's really [ __ ] i i i
mean i guess you should be thanking
trump for those gas price hikes right
right right right right it's uh it's
kind of ridiculous but you know it is
what it is yeah um so let's let's go
speaking of trump um let's go to the
poll here we had uh will smith of course
we know why will smith was on the poll
we're not even gonna go through that
again we did a whole thing on monday if
you want to know mine and gabe's stance
on will smith i think it still stands go
back to the monday show you will see it
there it even has will smith in the
title download it on apple spotify
google or go to the youtube channel and
watch it there um madison cawthorne we
know why he was on the pole i kind of
greased the skids here i tried to give
the sex orgies a head start i voted for
matt i wanted to vote for donald trump
because the reason why donald trump's on
here is because he loves putin and he's
trying to get russia
a time that there are our actual war
enemy
he's trying to get them to help him uh
win an election which he's not in it
yeah i mean sometimes you gotta
you gotta grease the wheels for speed
bumps you know oh yeah yeah
the in in the video
and um because you know a lot of people
i don't call him this a lot of people
call him sittler oh yeah yeah i've heard
that you know it's kind of it's kind of
i don't call him i don't yeah i don't
call him i don't call him sittler either
right um but speed bumps that now that
that is a new good nickname
speed bumps here um i don't know is
that's in the video that you get but um
um that's fantastic but donald trump is
on the bowl here thanks kathy yes kathy
with the super sticker the super sticker
thank you very much
for your support again you can get in
the super chat if you're on youtube just
go over to youtube and type the tony
michaels podcast and you will find the
podcast youtube page subscribe sub
sub and then go down to the comments and
like and so whatever you're supposed to
say on youtube yeah yeah okay okay so
donald trump here won the poll 42.2
percent um which is not
i mean it's not really surprising that
he won yeah someone said earlier that
anytime he's in the poll he would win
but i don't think that's uh that's not
true he's no yeah i don't think that's
true i don't i don't i think there's
been a time where
um he's been in the poll a couple he's
won i think two out of three times he's
been in the poll so we'd have to go back
and look yeah
we'd have to send it to the booth for
them to review but right right but
marjorie taylor green up until up until
this week was now she is undefeated in
bonehead of the week i believe but yeah
she is not totally undefeated where she
did lose in botany madness in the very
final hour against ron desantis um but
we have will smith madison clawthorne
and donald trump we also have a few
other characters here um this week you
know we guys we do a dishonorable
mention and the dishonorable mention is
kevin mccarthy now you think he might be
the hero here but he really did
he really did draw more attention to the
sex orgies by actually um having a
talking to
with madison cawthorn i mean you would
think like insurrection um him going
around talking about how you need to get
violent you need to use your second
amendment remedies you know all these
things that madison gotham are these
despicable things that a congress person
should not be saying should not be doing
should not be engaged in
you would think
saying that putin are that zielinski is
a thug and
um holding up putin
paddling around with folks like um mike
flynn and uh roger stone and alex jones
apparently i guess that's where the
sexfield orgies come in but you would
think you would think kevin mccarthy
would have enough sense to question him
on those things
but he really he really wanted to make
sure who was getting invited to these
sex field orgies apparently
which you know i i feel like it's uh
what is it this the streisand effect
right the barbra streisand effect where
it's like you don't want to talk about
it but and by addressing it you end up
causing more people to talk about it
yeah you know that's exactly what
happened and i think the republican
party is like
guilty of this
on repeat occasion right and we call it
projection a lot of times right exactly
and that's what it is
right and they're they're coming to it
and they're saying
don't don't focus on this don't look at
it and then realizing that by them you
know trying to deny it or them trying to
skirt away from it they're actually
drawing more people to look into it and
be like this is good
maybe there's something to this whole
cocaine field orgy thing like when you
have when you have when you have the
guys who you would like
in dc like you think about it it's not
just politicians in dc there's lobbyists
there's lawyers there's staff members i
mean there's all sorts of people in dc
that are
that aren't just politicians right that
have something to do with the federal
government
and then you think of people like roger
stone and alex jones you're like yeah
those dudes definitely if they had a
chance they're going to a sex field orgy
like 100 like totally uninvited like i
look at those guys as
uh
the people that hear
like
uh from a distance that there's
something happening and then they're
like oh [ __ ] we gotta go to that party
right right typically it might be like
matt gates and jim jordan that just like
show up to the party uninvited but in
this scenario i think it very much is
uh
uh roger stone and alex jones where they
hear this and like oh [ __ ] dude we gotta
go like let's go get a [ __ ] six pack
and like maybe a bottle of skull and uh
or like a pack of skull and a bottle of
vodka or whatever and they they show up
to the door and they think they like
ding dong and they show up and they're
like you know password and you know they
say password do you think there's a
password to the sex orgies i think
there's a password and they say the
password because they heard the password
and it might be like cuck or something i
don't know maybe it's like
it could be like what you're what like a
venmo handle what your venmo handle is
maybe right exactly and then
yeah and then you know roger stone is
like oh hold on i got joel greenberg's
and he like flashes joel greenberg's
venmo oh okay and then yeah he's like oh
entered and then they walk in and then
people are like
wait
who invited these [ __ ] i think that's
what it's like they show up uninvited
sneak their way in and then while all
eyes are like focused on the grand thing
they like as they enter the hall or
whatever this like sex dungeon is all
eyes turn back on them and then they get
kicked the [ __ ] out so that's the
closest they've ever gotten to these
weird [ __ ] sex parties i think is
them sneaking in or showing up at the
front door pressing the doorbell to be
like i'm trying to get on off the party
on joe greenberg credentials huh yeah
well you know you know this this is all
um coming full circle too because
for for [ __ ] i don't know how long q
anon's been accusing democrats in
hollywood oh yeah of having a uh
you know a blood sucking cabal and all
this weird stuff that they [ __ ]
believe and here you have republicans on
the hill having to have a conversation
with an actual sitting member of
congress and you have [ __ ] weirdos
out there like roger stone and now jones
coming to his defense and probably
probably madison cawthorne will make an
appearance on steve bannon's trader tv
to verify that no
uh kevin mccarthy didn't
didn't tell me this or didn't tell me
that
maybe maybe we should have made mccarthy
alpha cuck but we did make him the
dishonorable mention
uh for his barbra streisand moment as
you as you put it um
but we do have an alpha cuck which is
very interesting this morning we
actually slid this one in at the very
last moment i mean even we were chatting
last night and you know it's all we
didn't know who's going to be
the dishonorable mention in the alpha
cuck can present themselves in the last
few hours of like even five minutes up
till we die
exactly
and in our outlook is johnny van zandt
um do you want to explain who johnny van
zandt is and why
why this bonehead is the alpha cuck of
the week and why he's cucking
so johnny vanzant is the uh the
untalented brother what is it donnie
ronnie ronnie brian yeah rocky ronnie
johnny is the dad right isn't it is it a
dining room i i i don't [ __ ] know i
or someone in the rest of the group is
also named donny so there's donnie
johnny and ronnie okay sounds like a guy
ronnie van zandt is the original right
of leonard's real
yeah yeah
of the learners now johnny is like the
wish version of his brother okay
oh he's definitely the witch.com version
of something and uh it's like here you
show up to walmart and you're like i
want to
like i want the ronnie van zandt and
like oh we're all sold out and then
they're like well well we do johnny we
got the johnny uh and they're like oh is
that like the same thing and they're
like
[Music]
you remember you remember the movie
jingle all the way when arnold
schwarzenegger and sinbad are trying to
fight and like
want the ronnie van sant
oh you missed it and here's the thing
they're like they're like oh they're
like yeah we we got a a johnny van zant
and they're like oh yeah my kid won't
know the difference and they're like
just go pick it up in the discount bin
right right and then it knows the
[ __ ] difference right and then he
goes over there and they're like
actually we're giving these away now so
if you you don't even have to pay us
we'll pay you right yeah if you'll take
if you'll take 10 of them we'll actually
give you some
just just to give people a little bit of
history on leonard skynyrd uh leonard
skinner does use the confederate flag
originally in a lot of their in a lot of
their um shows they would have the
confederate flag behind them um and they
had it they had the famous song sweet
home alabama of course and i think
that's this song that we're going to
talk about why uh johnny manzant is the
uh is the alpha cuck um why
sweet home out because he called a sweet
florida which is kind of gross that he's
using the whole sweetness out of beverly
but ronnie vanzant for those who don't
know ronnie vanzant was not a bigot
right ronnie vanzant was not a bigot um
he actually uh
was for equal even though they did have
the confederate flag at the time um
before ronnie uh tragically died um but
but uh they
leonard skinnered at the time ronnie
vincent d talented ronnie vanzant the
original legion the original
um he actually he actually um
was not a bigot his brother apparently
though
has bought into bigotry hook line singer
by um cocking a song for ronda santa so
what is this song is this did he like
write this song because i i see part of
the video
let me see i'm making the assumption
that he did write the song
like without without uh you know
i think this is a solo project
but who knows maybe he hired someone to
write the lyrics but i don't know like
i'm not sure if one's giving him more
credit or not it's just funny that this
is actual news coverage
because the actual song i don't want to
play the actual song [ __ ] this song i
don't want to play this song um uh aaron
here let's see i think this is this the
one i want to play this one
yes it says worst cult personality ever
um
is this the i think this may be the one
that we want to play let's watch this
and turn the music off i don't i don't i
don't even want to have the music on so
you see here that he's really cooking
for
oh yeah it's really gross it's really
gross it is gross you guys can go watch
this video um i'm not gonna play the
video because uh
it just gives van zant the uh the
opportunity what i find funny about this
is that it says new song highlights the
leadership of governor desantis if
someone can point me to said leadership
i will love to read about it because
i haven't seen any sort of leadership
when it came to covid relief uh
protocols uh just healthcare also taking
credit for infrastructure like what
leadership has been there where the guys
actually stepped in and taken care like
do does leadership like try to scold
kids who
uh who are wearing masks in the backdrop
of some uh of like a photo opportunity
is what it was like no that's not what
leaders do leaders don't uh make their
constituents or others try to feel bad
and shame them
constituents don't
let you know
people die
of a uh what has now become you know
through
different protocols vaccine masks and
distance like things that can be
prevented he just said ah [ __ ] it it's
spring break every day down here in
florida right well [ __ ] he said that not
a hundred not three not 93 193
republicans
voted against the life-saving drug
insulin to be to be affordable for
america which i don't understand because
that's something that is a huge argument
of donald trump lowered the prices of
insulin which he never died oh chris in
kristin has been in the chat all [ __ ]
day talking about hit chris where are
you chris chris you're out there chris
was in the chat earlier talking about
how donald trump had it at 35
so if that's the case if that really is
the case and these republicans are
voting for it
is the idea now that republicans are
anti-trump
yeah because i don't know i would love
to hear i would love to see chris's
response here right here okay
explain this
you believe that donald trump lowered
the cost of insulin that's the big
platform move on big pharma and going
against them then why would republicans
almost unanimously
be for big pharma
yeah why would they why would they say
you know what let's let big pharma hike
up the prices so people who actually
have this and can't afford it will no
longer be accessible
chris do you want the answer gabe that's
because republicans have always
have always been for big pharma they're
for big pharma they're for big oil
that's why big oil is remaining to gouge
the american people because the
republican party has convinced the
american people that it's biden's fault
and as long as the american people are
are consistently in polls blaming joe
biden for gas prices oil companies will
not be held accountable and they do not
think they'll be held accountable and
they will continue to gouge you
they will continue because you and your
stupidity is blaming the wrong person
you're directing your aim in the wrong
direction
and you need to be directing it at
republicans
and by the way by the way donald trump
didn't lower the price of
insulin yep he did not lower the price
of insulin also the claim when i think
it was yeah it was donald trump that's
that insulin is as cheap as water oh
full [ __ ] [ __ ] it is that is not true
and i see chris over here saying
uh i i don't believe it it happened
what's the argument chris what we're
talking about is the fact that
republicans voted to allow
pharmaceutical companies to raise the
price of insulin right
so explain that what happened there
right right 193 of them all of them
pretty much not three not 93
193
posted up
with big pharma they are in bed with big
pharma by the way uh yesterday or was it
the day before iver mechton was trending
again because there was a big huge study
about how i don't know
and the craziest part the [ __ ]
stupidest [ __ ] argument i get because
i i think might just put a clip of me
talking about ivermectin on um uh we did
on instagram and the biggest [ __ ]
argument was well i've cause i say in
the clip
big pharma makes ivermectin and they're
like uh it's generic i'm like oh my god
who the [ __ ] do you think makes generic
drugs do you think there's mom and pop
stores down the street that are
producing generic drugs it's big pharma
who invented ivermectin it's big pharma
who owns the patent of ivermectin even
in a generic setting it's big pharma who
is making and manufacturing ivermectin
rather it's the [ __ ] patented one
that merck had or the generic one you
dumb
it's
capitalism
pluck your head
out of your ass
and believe your own [ __ ] [ __ ]
your own boneheaded [ __ ] talking
about boneheads of the week so uh
i guess to come full circle here
um we do have uh donald trump will smith
and madison gawthorne on
the bonehead of the week donald trump
wins the bone of the week i want to get
the bonehead madness here um so we can
get to the champion there but not only
did donald trump win
donald trump wins the bonehead of the
week but he brings along with him
kristin and all his supporters who
believe all his [ __ ] chris we do
appreciate you being a hate watcher here
please don't stop uh and and please
comment um with
and please send us some uh send us some
money too yeah yeah absolutely get a
super chat we want to make sure that we
continue to have a place for you to come
and be
and be a donald trump supporter inside
the polls
and a putin supporter along with it with
donald trump trying to collude with
russia and collude with putin to win an
election that hasn't even started yet um
let's do this let's give donald trump
his due
[Applause]
[Music]
that
thanks to the trump supporters i guess
and donald trump for and chris says yeah
i know you love me um you know chris we
love having uh anyone here who wants to
watch we love hate watchers we love
trolls as long as you don't get the
bigoted and racist and ridiculous in the
comments uh we do appreciate that you
don't do that chris so um you we believe
in freedom of ideas and freedom of
speech and you have the right to be
wrong yeah that is the right thing yeah
you have the right to be wrong a lot of
the time
and right now
you are doing it
oh man holy [ __ ] you are wrong it's
incredible thank you kristen uh for
being our our our local uh punching bag
today um
so let's get to that's bonehead of the
week
we gave donald trump as due um let's
talk about the bonehead madness thing
for real quick we got about 15 minutes
left in the show i want to give the
champion their due here
um it's not surprising really who won i
was disappointed but
um let's let's um i guess at the end of
the day it was all about who's the
bigger fascist right
well i think so yeah yeah i mean that
that could be it well who's more
pro-putin maybe um because that was
really the theme of the bonehead of the
week poll i think the reason why people
voted for donald trump is because the
guy was supporting a murderous dictator
i mean he's been calling for a murderous
dictator to help him win
uh back the the united and not only that
russia and putin said our partner trump
we want him to be the president united
states so that way he can be a murderous
dictator all around the world and they
can together
together in their loving relationship
they can destroy democracy yes partners
they can destroy democracy all around
the world so that way uh there is no
human rights there is no uh there is no
equality there is no equity there is no
liberty they don't want liberty why
would they want liberty liberty
threatens their power well they only
want i mean it's not liberty for all but
it's liberty for some yeah right i mean
they want to have the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people right which
isn't liberty right exactly you know we
say that on the show every single day
every single weekday that that theme
song starts with the phrase the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people
is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] so let's
uh let me see if i can pull up the uh
the podcast page here um
here it is here we go here's the graphic
let's pull it up here here is let's pull
this banner down here oh you've got the
you got the um you got the championship
okay i got there yeah well here here is
here's the the um
the final round it was um tucker carlson
and ron desantis
as it were in the bonehead championship
now again
um ron desantis came in at the last hour
i mean the very last hour to to box out
marjorie taylor yeah and i really
because of that gabe i really did have
ron desantis pulling this out in this
final championship game of bonehead
madness against tucker carlson i really
did i
yeah i thought the same i thought ron
desantis was really gonna take it home
you know with all the [ __ ] that he's
been pulling but right it turns out that
people looked at tucker carlson as a
bigger threat you know i i think that's
what happened i believe that we had a
situation where in the championship game
um it was just the threat
of a fascist who is supporting putin
in this war on democracy i really think
that was the most boneheaded thing now
not to say that ron desantis isn't part
of the machine in this war against
democracy because he definitely he
definitely is a person who loves to
oppress the rights of other people and
take away people's liberty i mean all of
it he wants to take away all your
liberty if you live in florida so much
so that he'll get ronnie or ronnie i'm
not running johnny donna
bonnie what whoever the [ __ ] this guy is
this vanzant [ __ ] discount
discount rowney ronnie wanted you know
yeah just a discount vanzant uh
character to do sweet florida and do a
song for his campaign so much so yeah
because remember you know ron desantis
is the guy you know the republican party
is the party that says you know freedom
of speech right first amendment that's
the one we we only care about the first
and the second amendment all the other
ones go [ __ ] themselves this is the
fifth amendment and then i need to
protect myself as to not incriminate wow
but really they don't even understand
those three amendments right exactly but
the first amendment they say freedom of
speech you know uh big tech shouldn't be
able to suppress our voice they
shouldn't be able to silence us we
should be able to say what we want and
be as bigoted as we want right you
should be able to say and do whatever
you want because that's [ __ ] america
and then they're like hey you're gay now
[ __ ] that don't say it don't say it yeah
don't even say that you're don't even if
you think it just
right and they're gonna they're gonna
start passing don't say gay bills all
around the country i wouldn't be
surprised and i'm gonna look into this
week because i want to start a i want to
start a thing here where we find the
next don't say gay um and i don't know
if we make a segment on it or something
but we're gonna find because they're
gonna do it they're gonna do it folks
now that florida's done it they're all
these red states are gonna try to out
florida florida and these republicans
are gonna try to out florida florida so
they're gonna have don't say gay bills
all around the country to really gear up
for the midterm of 2020 to prove to
everyone in the country why they
shouldn't be in charge yeah but ron
desantis here really disappointed me
really [ __ ] disappointed me i wanted
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] to win so bad
oh my god i wanted him to win i know i
know but i voted i voted for myself i
really thought was ron ahead at some
point
uh
i don't recall i looked at it when it
first went live ron was i guess in the
first like 10 or so votes that i saw he
was obviously winning but then i
i checked out and i didn't want to you
know it was one of those like can't look
at it right now get ready
when it's over
because i think he was ahead at some
point because i voted for ron here you
see the check mark here yeah indicates
that i on my account voted for ron
desantis um because i believe
um what he is doing by legislating it's
not just his opinion see i get that [ __ ]
a lot you know in the comments of things
uh videos we post stuff we say they'll
be like oh you're just trying to silence
someone's opinion like okay tucker
carlson has the right to be on a
broadcast right i'm not going to review
that and really as long as he's not
saying things that endanger people which
he's bordering on right he has the right
to say his i mean i don't know i would
say that in some ways tucker carlson has
already endangered lives by the things
that he said which is like either
pushing disinformation around covid
right or it's pushed the narrative that
we should be pro-russia or pro-putin
anti-ukraine because they're you know
it's hunter biden's laptop and it's joe
biden and it's zelinski and they are the
evil people in the situation
laptop is an evil person by the way it
is if you're not aware hunter biden's
laptop is the biggest national security
threat yeah that we have and it's
hacking the moral code right of this
country you know did you know that the
uh hunter binds laptop um they actually
are going to release a statement
later on next week
to the actual i ai the artificial
intelligence code that runs jared
kushner did you know that i'm just
saying i'm just saying
breaking news right here on
you hunter biden lands out people really
are [ __ ] dumb okay so
but you are right that tucker carlson
probably has said some really dangerous
things
but you do have the right in this
country to be a bigot you have the right
in this country to harbor
racist bigoted um ideas fascist ideas
you do have that right in this country
it is called freedom now what you don't
have the right to do though in this
country is to take those ideas become in
power and then legislate them and put
them into policy that is not a right
that's not speech anymore that's not
your opinion and anyone out there who
[ __ ] says any of these laws that
these [ __ ] fascists are pushing and
trying to legislate is opinion
you are a [ __ ] bonehead and you
should be in the bonehead madness you
should be on the bone end of the week
because you are a [ __ ] bonehead when
you think that policy
when policy
is opinion it's not opinion anymore
right it never was never will be when
you're legislating it so that is
important that's why i felt like that
ron desantis had a really good chance of
winning this but obviously everyone
and maybe i should have known this that
if if tucker because you know as the
late great george carlin says
uh [ __ ] tucker tucker sucks um you know
maybe i should have known from the very
beginning that tucker carlson was gonna
win this thing yeah i
you know i i think
it's
tucker is a
is a threat in many ways to
uh democracy
oh absolutely and
the the way that he uses his platform
for evil and not good
uh because rarely if ever have i seen
him say something in the positive light
to say like hey the country's doing
pretty good good job right or like this
is a great example of this or it's
always been how
democrats bad republicans good you know
this person's bad this person's good
this person's evil you know that type of
narrative which you know obviously is
totally fair to say on the left as well
in terms of how
you politic against each other
but tucker carlson
also remember
had to go to [ __ ] court and had the
lawyers at fox news say that no one
who like no real sane person should
believe the things that tucker says
because they said that in in in court
like yeah officials
and he got out of the lawsuit that was
brought up against him because they said
actually tucker carlson isn't news he's
entertainment which i would say is fair
to say for most of fox news um that
they're not actually right the only
person
we don't claim to be news here right now
we're just commentary
we're just commenting on things and
here's the thing tucker carlson has an
entertainment show he doesn't have a new
show okay the only person the last
person that had a new show on fox news
was chris wallace right okay that was
the last person and that's gone bye-bye
right and he's gone because he was like
i couldn't take this [ __ ] anymore i had
to go and i was like i'm surprised you
even stayed that long honestly
so tucker carlson is uh you know spreads
propaganda disinformation and also is
anti-democratic that's the those are
like the three pillars and if you want
to throw a fourth one in there for like
bigot go right ahead but those are the
pillars in which tucker carlson
sits up like that's where he stands
that's where he he holds his show and
his voice on those pillars to be like
these are the things that i'm going to
spread
some random conspiracy [ __ ] it let's do
it you know
so you're so you're saying tucker
carlson doesn't even have to make it to
the credential of bigotry to be such a
[ __ ] bonehead and win bonehead
madness that is yeah he's got other he's
got other pillars to lean on wait wait
wait way more [ __ ] that he does
well tucker carlson congratulations on
winning the bracket here um he is the
bonehead
madness champion
and i'm i'm disappointed um on a couple
different levels number one that uh ron
desantis maybe didn't beat tucker
carlson but it's your guys's vote we go
through the vote just like we go through
the vote and the other thing i'm really
disappointed that marjorie taylor green
didn't pull out on ron desantis so we
could call it
merge
merge
marge madness
with march madness marge madness that's
the beauty of the bracket baby well you
know maybe there's always next year
there is always next year i'm sure next
year um during march sometime yeah we'll
probably do like a bonehead madness
bracket thing you know it just so
happens to be in march look if other
people out there lincoln project want to
come and
uh partner together instead of stealing
ideas right you could just ask us if you
want to do a video just be like hey you
want to collaborate on something you
want to use the branding i think it was
a great video the manga madness it was a
great video based on our content it was
fantastic yeah it was great they were
like hey look at that final four bracket
we should definitely use
yeah so lincoln project we really are
flattered that you uh found our content
i mean that's what they say right
they're you know it's a it's a form of
flattery right when people copy you so
thanks lincoln project for the third
[ __ ] time
and by the way uh shout out uh rick
wilson if you'd like to come on and
explain yeah um why you like gabe and
and the podcast content so much like
bone ed madness would be like to come on
and explain we would welcome you on the
show please live we would do a recorded
interview live however you want to do it
right we would love it i want to talk it
out because here's the thing and i told
tony this yesterday
that those pieces of content are
approved okay by certain people in your
organization whether it is you at the
top or someone else right someone's eyes
are on it which means that you at the
top just like any big company right you
could throw other people under the bus
but you are responsible because you gave
the final sign off on that content so
whoever at [ __ ] lincoln project is
stealing these ideas okay
i want you on the show yeah and if that
means rick wilson needs to own up to
those sins of someone else then bring
him on right rick come on we'll we'll
talk to you buddy we love to have you on
to talk politics and
to get to the bottom of why you love
the content here so much and why it's um
such a hard thing to get just to get a
message to a guy like hey we like your
content let's um
let's let's we want to do a video based
on bonehead madness well that's that's
bonehead of the week thanks for joining
us stick around for announcements we'll
be right back after the song here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]